بادئ ذي بدء ، أنا ممتن جدًا
لحضور صاحب السمو الملكي ،
لقد كان لشرف لي أن أكون هنا على الرغم من أنني
لا أسمي نفسي ضيفًا ، فأنا
جزء من هذا البلد وجزء من العائلة
، وأعتزم التنافس مع السعوديين
الذين حضروا
كأس العالم ،
وجلبوا السعادة والعاطفة
، وأظهروا ذلك الفرح والعاطفة
والحب لهذا البلد وشعبه ،
لذا
فأين أنا وما أكون هنا من أجل
الاسترخاء ، فأنا أعلم أن هذه التفاصيل هي نعم.
الناس أه نأخذ الأمور في
خط عرض مختلف ،
نحن نركز على الصورة الأكبر ، نعم
الفروق الدقيقة في اليوم
وغدًا ، وبعد الغد مهمة ولكننا
نتعامل معهم بشكل تكتيكي ،
نحن في المملكة العربية السعودية لدينا رؤية
تسمى 2030. هذا هو محركنا الرئيسي ، كل
شيء
يدور حوله ، لذا
مهما كان ما إذا سأل الناس أحيانًا عما
ينوون القيام به هنا وهناك
كل ما أحتاج لإخبارهم
به ، سنقوم فقط بالعودة وقراءة ما لدينا
من إجابات.